Candid Truth. What is up everybody?
Thank you for joining us at Candid
Truth. We're going to talk about the
truth and we're going to get candid with
it. I got my brother Minnow here again.
If you guys didn't check out part one
yesterday, you guys need to check that
out. But you are in for a treat with
part two because Minnow is going to be
exposing the golden age that Trump is
bringing in. What is up,
Minnow? Oh, I can't hear you, bro. You
might be muted.
Oh man, is it me? What's up? Live, live,
live
always. Huh? I don't know what to do.
Anybody else
here? Any
sound from
Let me see. Do I have you muted? What's
going on here? Do you hear me now? I
hear you. Yes. All right. What is up,
Minnow?
Sorry, man. Doing good, man. A little
bit a little bit more rested as you can
see. A little bit. Uh yeah, man. Quite
the trip to to Vegas. was late uh
preparing everything. So now I'm a
little bit more rested. So let's go.
Awesome. Cool, man. Well, I'm excited to
see what you got cuz yesterday was so in
your face that all roads all roads lead
to Rome. Every single one of them,
especially America, but when you look
all around the world, it's it's not just
America. It's all roads. Because Bible
prophecy is true. We know that Satan is
trying to bring everybody into a one
world religion of sun worship and that
it's coming through all these different
forms of politics, religion,
AI, Angel Studios, everything. And what
I thought was amazing yesterday near the
end of yesterday uh yesterday's show,
you you started showing these people
that were on the board of uh Trump's
cabinet or whatever. I don't know all
the political jargon, but and you
started showing that whether you're
Republican or Democrat, you got the same
agenda going on. The Republicans got the
same thing. It's all AI,
um,
Catholicism, space. Yeah. It's all this
same stuff. So, it just proves that
right and left are both wings of the
same bird. Your votes don't matter.
Nothing's nothing changes. It's all an
illusion of freedom of choice. You get
to choose your puppet master, your slave
master, but really the votes don't
count. It's all it's all a pendulum
effect. It's all left, right, left,
right, just to keep the masses from
having an uprising basically. But the
agenda is still the same. Satan is the
god of this world. But but but isn't it
interesting? I I thought about it for a
for a while. Um
so if so if the Bible tells us that uh
God is putting leaders in place right
God is putting kings in place. So what
happens if we vote then it's our
decision? So are we making ourselves God
then? Very interesting very good point
because I mean right? No, that's a great
point because some people will say it's
our responsibility whether you believe
it's, you know, it's matters or not. We
still as Christians have a
responsibility to vote and and some
people say you need to vote for what
does it say in the Bible? It doesn't,
you know, I don't see it either.
Exactly. And people say vote for the
third party, but a third party never
wins. It's it's like wasting your time.
Well, third party this time was Kennedy.
It's any better, right? Wow. So, yeah,
it's I think it's an illusion. I think
it's set up to to everything is pointing
like setting you up to be to be God
yourself, right? Uh new age or uh if you
if you're Mormon or whatever it is, it's
all about self. Self love, selfishness,
it's all elevating yourself. Uh become a
god. Even the Catholicism, right? U yeah
God became man so that man can become
God. that's that's their that's what
they say what they believe. Uh there's
nothing else than Mormonism. Um and this
is another another form of um like oh
yeah it's your responsibility as you
said but no it's not it's not my
responsibility it's it's God's
responsibility.
Good point man.
Well should we get into the presentation
here? Let's let's go. So is this uh the
first slide? Yeah. What is this slide
talking about?
So this side is b b b b b b b b b b b b
b b b b b b b b b b b b b b b b b b b b
b b b b b b b b basically this is
Trump's Trump's house. Um it's very
interesting to see here. Uh I'll just
read the text here. Take a look inside
the new newly elected president of the
USA. This is from last time that he was
elected. Uh but uh you know, president
of the United States, Donald Trump's
opulent Manhattan penthouse located at
the Trump Tower in Manhattan, New York.
Donald and Melania Trump live on the top
three floors which is the 66th floor.
Very interesting. Goodness. Of this uh
yeah of this grand penthouse with
breathtaking views of Central Park and
Manhattan. Now uh there are a couple
things that we're going to see in this
house. You can go to the next
slide. Uh so the Trump apartment
decorated in 24 carats of gold and
marble.
Uh gold, right? the golden age decked
with gold and precious stones.
Yes. Yes. And an image of uh Rome. Uh it
was designed by Anglo Dong Dong Dongja
also ref uh referred to as the Saint
Laurent of Sofas in Louis
um I think it's the 14th style. Uh when
it came to creating the ultimate
luxurious home for the Donald, the
Donald, he kept Louis uh the King Louie
in mind while picking furniture and
textiles. Where did we see King Louie
again? Oh yeah, that was the We saw him
uh pictured uh in uh in um uh the was it
the the Supreme Court? Remember I
mentioned that we were talking about him
yesterday. Yeah.
So again, it's very interesting even
though he's French. Uh we we come to the
to we we'll come to to uh King Louie in
a second after this, but uh keep keep
that in mind because a lot of his a lot
of it is is referring to King Louie. Uh
this is the Donald Melania Trump's New
York uh city penthouse is on the 66th
floor as it just mentioned
uh of Trump Tower and features marble
walls, floors and columns throughout 24
karat gold accents like platters, lamps,
phases and crown molding that outline
outlines each room and tableau ceilings.
Art of the
dealmaker. Classic art dominates
dominates here with a bronze of aos and
psyche. Uh one of the great love Greek
love uh stories. Um and Apollo led by
Aurora, the Greek goddess of the dawn.
Uh suggesting Trump sees himself the
mold of Apollo, Zeus son and one of the
most powerful of the gods.
That's crazy. Zeus's
son. Man, all this stuff like it's
whether it's in the Library of Congress
or in Washington DC or whatever or in
Trump's own personal home, it's all
Greek and Roman mythology and the sun
god and all this stuff.
Wow, dude. It's amazing. And and and
people are like, "Yeah, he's a
Christian." Like, if he is really a
Christian, this was not in his home
anymore, right? He is very deceived. Um,
how I don't know. I since I've been in
ministry for seven years and in the
specifically in the ministry of exposing
Satan's deception, Satan's lies, I see
how Satan truly is deceiving the whole
world. And in one way or another, he's
got you somehow. Whether it's the you're
just you're justifying the entertainment
you watch which is blasphemous,
adulterous, murderous, witchcraft, all
that. Or if you don't watch those, maybe
you're keeping the holidays, these pagan
rooted holidays, Christmas, Easter, all
these things. Or um keeping the
venerable day of the sun instead of the
Sabbath or it's like he has a million
different ways to trick you and stuff
like this. It's just like, oh, it's just
it's just decorative, you know? I just
uh it just looks pretty or whatever.
It's just art. Yeah. I mean, dude, you
go to TJ Maxx or any of these like home
decor places and you see Buddha statues
and people are like, "Oh, that looks,
you know, that's so beautiful. I'm going
to take that home." and bringing idols
into your home. When you read uh
Ezekiel, I think it's Ezekiel, Isaiah or
Ezekiel, I always get this too confused,
but there's a vision given where God
opens up a hole in the temple walls and
he goes in and he's facing the east and
all this stuff and it says there were
all these idols on the walls in the
church and like you know our home needs
to be the church as well. We are the the
temple of God and we shouldn't have any
of this stuff in our
homes. And to have Zeus and Apollo and
all this stuff in your home on the 66th
floor of all things is just wow, man.
Super crazy.
All decorated in gold, right? Yeah. So
this this is uh the meas Donald and
Melania's breakfast room is packed with
in intricate uh details including a gold
rimmed cla glass of orange juice sitting
on top of a gold tray, a gold rimmed
teacup uh and an art uh antique clock.
The furniture is also Louis the king.
All about the details. A fountain sits
in the back of the Trump's uh in Trump's
sitting room behind it semi-ircle ivory
couch. A crystal chandelier uh lights it
up its beauty as it is planted on the
tableau ceiling above it shows a scene
of of Greek or Roman gods and seems
likely to be Apollo again who is often
portrayed crossing the heavens in his
chariot. Wow, man. This is so You see
that on the right where where Trump is
uh is standing. Yeah. This on the left
on the on the bottom.
Yep. Wow. Yeah, I see it. Oh, dude. This
stuff's so crazy.
Yeah, it's Apollo. Uh so Apollo Well,
Apollo is one of the Olympian deities in
ancient Greek and Roman religion and
Greek and Roman mythology. Apollo has
been recognized as a god of archery,
music, and dance. Truth and prophecy.
Well, not truth, healing and
diseases. Interesting. Uh, the sun and
light poetry and more. One of the most
important and complex of the Greek gods.
He is the son of Zeus and Leto and the
twin brother of Artemis, goddess of the
hunt. As the patron deity of Deli, uh,
Apollo
Potheio, Apollo is an oracular god. the
prophetic deity of the delac uh oracle
and also the deity of ritual p
purification. His oracles were often uh
consulted for guidance in various
matters. He was in in general uh in
general seen as the god who affords help
and words of evil and and referred to as
uh Alexi Kakus the averter of evil.
Medicine and healing are associated with
Apollo whether through the god himself
or medi mediated through his son as a
lepius. Apollo delivered people from
epidemics. H really yet he is also a god
who could bring ill health and deadly
plague with his arrows. Oh interesting.
Yeah. The the the thing the the the
thing, right? The arrow that goes into
your body, right?
The the invention uh of archery itself
is credited to Apollo and his sister
Artemis. Uh Apollo is usually described
as carrying a silver or golden bow and a
quiver of silver or golden arrows. It's
so interesting.
Yeah, dude. That is nuts.
So, these people are clearly spiritist.
Um, it's talking about the oracles and
stuff. That's exactly what Trump is
rolling out with Stargate, which is
created by the company Oracle,
which is a prophetic god. And the fact
that this guy Apollo, you know, it's all
about
controlling pharmacy and pharmacia and
disease and pandemics and that was an
interesting connection. Stargate about
right Stargate Stargate was about also
about med medication about uh about that
whole thing. So uh the uh the he said
there'll be there'll be an individual
vaccine for every specific person
because different people have different
body makes and stuff. So AI will analyze
your body and give you the perfect
vaccine for you and it's going to be
like copyright to your person basically.
Wow. Somebody asked um why is Apollo
associated with healing?
because like
Mercury or or kaducus. So the kaducus
which you see around the the serpents
with the wings around the staff that is
the staff carried by the god Hermes. And
when you look into what that is, it says
that he is the guide of the dead,
protector of liars, thieves, merchants.
And it's like, dude, you read
Revelation, that's exactly what it says,
that the world is going to be deceived
by Pharmarmacia. And it says that that
it'll be the the merchants of the world
are the great men, the merchants, and
they're the ones that are deceiving the
world through Pharmarmacia. And you got
this
kaducus, literally a symbol that we all
look to as medical help. Like today, we
think that symbol means, oh, I'm going
to get help from the doctors. But it's a
Greek and Roman. It just depends on
Greek and Roman. All they do is they
have the same gods repackaged. So it's
like it's Mercury and Hermes or yeah
Mercury and and Greek or Roman and
Hermes in the other one. They're the
same god holding the staff of the
kaducus and they are the guide of the
dead, the protector of liars, thieves,
and merchants which are the elite right
there. So this God
being a a healer, he's healing the
elites, keeping them youthful with the
dare I say some of the flagged words,
but um the elixir of life and and their
occult
circles coming from children and all
this stuff, uh adrenochrome and all
that. So that's that's what I think it's
talking about. We're using all all the
all the all all the flags. Yeah. Let's
just say let's just put it out there,
man. God help the algorithm. Say it as
it is.
Yep. Truth must be told. Well, who is
King Louie the 14th? It's a French king.
Louie is Louis the Great. Well, we have
had Alexander the Great. Now we have
Louis the Great. Uh or referenced as the
Sun King. Uh interesting. The Sun King.
He was of course a Catholic. And what
what was the role of France again?
France again with the United States. Oh,
we got the Statue of Liberty or Lucifer.
I mean, yeah. Well, well, they they
captured the Pope and and were the first
country to recognize the United States
as a country, right? That's that's
something that France did as well. Oh,
yeah. Uh he was a believer in a divine
uh right of kings. Uh Louie also
enforced uniformity of religion under
the Catholic Church. His revocation of
the addict of Nantis abolished the
rights of the hugenot protestant
minority and subjected them to a wave of
dragons effectively forcing hugenauts to
immigrate immigrate or immigrate or
convert virtually destroying the French
Protestant community. Oh my goodness. If
if if if Trump is is having all these
artifacts in his home by from Louie,
King Louie, the sun referring to the sun
god, the sun king and all these
elements. Is is it a coincidence that in
first or second episode that uh the
Jesuit um uh guy uh one of the
aristocrats, right, the one of those
black nobility was at his home. Oh yeah.
Mhm. Uh and that was they were that he
comes from the family that uh uh you
know wanted to rekindle the the the
reformation. I mean everything together
you know uh shows the same thing. Yeah.
If you guys are just watching this, you
got to go back and watch part one
because
uh Trump is referred to as a Roman
Caesar and as Constantine who was the
first one to bring about the first
Sunday law. The venerable day of the sun
must be kept by law and you must not be
caught uh Judaizing and all that stuff.
Now his whole house is decked with King
Louie who is the king, the sun king who
destroyed
Protestantism literally
meaning implementing by law Catholicism
which is sun worship. This is all about
bringing you back to pagan Roman sun
worship. And so if this is your first
time ever hearing anything like this,
the way we understand prophecy is
that there's going to be it's a pendulum
effect. There's going to be order out of
chaos when the world is so crazy, so far
liberal left that the world is sick of
it. They're going to be saying we need
change and Trump is going to bring in
the change. That's why they got project
2025 saying he can enact any religious
law he wants to. He's going to go for a
third term. is saying um he's saying if
you vote for me you'll never have to
vote again. So he's already portraying
himself as a king who can enact any law
he wants to. This is danger red flag
danger. Like anyone that comes in in a
power in the seat of the the um most
powerful nation on earth who has the
power to enact religious laws. You're
talking about the dark ages all over
again. Revived. Dark Age is revived.
Worship this way or be burned at the
stake. That's where we're That's where
we're racing to right now. Controlled by
AI surveillance. AI
governance. Nuts,
bro. I can't believe how clear it is,
man. Here. Yeah. Here's more. So, King
Louie uh the 14th, the French king
again. Uh Louis the Great. Oh, is this
the same?
Uh yeah, I think you covered. This is
No, this is the same. Okay. Yeah. So
what is the dragoness? The dragons was a
policy implemented by the king Louie in
1681 to force French Protestants known
as hugenauts to convert to Catholicism.
It involved the billeting of dragon
dracoons of the French royal army in
hugenot households with the soldiers
being given in uh implied uh permission
to mistreat the inhabitants and damage
or steal the processions. soldiers
employed as part of this policy were uh
derisively referred to as missionary
draons and king Louie however aimed to
have religious uniformity uniformity in
his kingdom in it initially he offered
the hugenauts financial incentives to
convert
but this had yeah this had limited
effect by the late 1670s he decided upon
a harsher policy. He began the order to
the order the destruction of Hugenot
churches and the closure of Hugenot
schools. Uh okay. So yeah, this guy
because they didn't take the financials.
Yeah, because he did the the guys didn't
take the the bait then for the finances
uh sort of for the benefits. Uh they
destroy he we went from uh basically
from manipulation he went to destroying.
So he it's two tactics, right? It's
either manipul manipulation or it is um
what is the other one is like uh
oppression, right? So either you
manipulate or you oppress. Yep. And
that's dude when you when you really
have your eyes open to what's been going
on in history like everything has been
orchestrated even down to wars and the
Great Depression and all this stuff,
dude. It's all been orchestrated to it's
it's called the indust uh uh what is it
called? the military-industrial complex.
Like, this is what they're doing.
It's how do you think that companies
like ammo producing companies and tank
building companies and all this stuff
stay in business? Because every so often
it's like, well, we need to have a war.
And then they bring in all the, you
know, now now the factories are firing
up. We're building tanks and ammo and
all this stuff. The military-industrial
complex. This
guy destroyed Protestantism, which if
you don't know what Protestantism is,
most Christians are fall under
evangelical Protestantism. And the word
protest, it means to protest the
Catholic Church. That's where it came
from. The reformation meant to reform
the church, get away from traditions of
men, which are actually paganism, and
come back to the Bible. Solos
scriptorra. That's where you get
Protestants. We're all protesting the
Catholic Church. we should be. But now
in this day and age, all evangelicals
and Protestants are joining hands and
saying, "No, we're all children of God.
Let's all you unite." And the Pope has
these commercials saying, "We all have
the same God. We all worship love and
all this stuff." So this guy who
destroyed Protestantism to basically
enforce
paganism.
Um, man, what was I getting to? He said
uh and if you know if they didn't take
the financial bribe then he'd bring
destruction. Now what are we racing
towards? We got a guy who can enact
religious laws, who's calling himself a
king, calling himself Constantine, all
these things, AI governance, and uh his
sidekick Elon Musk is saying AI is going
to take over so many jobs that we
basically need to have a new universal
income where everybody gets allowances.
Basically, we're racing towards a
society where nobody has jobs, everyone
has a social credit score. If you don't
do the right thing and play by their
rules, your social credit score goes
down. You don't get to buy and sell. You
don't get to eat. You don't get to
travel. And by force of uh starvation or
whatever, you will conform or
die. And
uh what's the bribe? Well, in the golden
age, everybody's going to be it's going
to be great, right? The golden age is
all about everybody has everything,
right? We're all rich and we can sit
there and shop on T-Mu all day and watch
streaming everything as long as you
comply to the universal church system,
the one world religion that that
revelation tells us is coming, a one
world religion. Yeah. What what what did
the guy from oracle say? Right. Uh it's
like we make them conform, right? Yes.
By uh by he said people will behave when
every move you make is watched by AI.
Yep. Crazy dude. That's insane, man. Oh
man. And what do we see here? Yeah. Here
you see he who saves his country does
not violate any law. Where does he come
from? Oh, Trump appears to channel
Napoleon in vision for executive
authority. He who saves his country does
not violate any law. Is that crazy?
Another Napoleon was what? Oh, yeah. He
was a Freemason. He was what? Oh, yeah.
He uh he was from Italian descent. Oh,
Italy. Rome. Italy.
Wow. His daddy was Italian.
Dude, this is crazy, man. So, he keeps
comparing himself to people from Rome
one way or another. There there's there
there's one video that I saw that he put
himself he was he was on a on a rooftop
and he said uh that he compared himself
with uh Alexander the great Napoleon and
some others uh and oh yeah and a
Constantine or so or was Constantine or
so no maybe not Constantine this time
some of maybe it was I don't know but
was he himself said it right uh years
ago on a rooftop
Uh, I saw it yesterday. One of the
people that responded has its own
channel and I watched the the the video
of that person. I forgot. Uh, sorry if
uh something like the
um well, we'll put it in the chat below
later, but uh uh yeah, it's crazy
bizarre.
What's going on? This is Napoleon,
right? Who's Napoleon? Um Napoleon is uh
another French so-called hero and
Freemason. Surprise Napoleon's family
was uh ital from Italian origin. his
paternal ancestors. The Buunopart Buana
Buana descendant descended from a minor
Tuscan noble noble family who immigrated
uh to Corsica in the 16th century and
his maternal ancestors the Ramol
Ramolinos descendant from a noble family
from Lomb Lombardi.
Wow, dude. These are right. Napoleon was
baptized as a Catholic under the name
Napoleon de Buanarta.
Wow. Born apart. Isn't it is it
interesting? After a decade of war,
France and Britain signed the treaty of
uh a amines in March 1802, bringing the
revolutionary wars to an end. Under the
treaty, Britain agreed to withdraw from
most of the col colony colonies it had
recently captured from France and her
allies and France agreed to evacuate
Naples. In April, Bonapart uh publicly
celebrated the peace and his
controversial
concordat treaty of 1801 with Pope Pius
the 7th under which the pope recognized
Bonapart's regime and the regime
recognized Catholicism as the majority
religion of France. In a further step
towards national cons reconciliation
known as fusion, Bonapart offered an
amnesty to most immigr uh im immigrants
who wished to turn uh return to France.
Whoa, man. So you see him doing the
hidden hand symbol and and he was a
baptized Catholic
Freemason. Catholicism and Freemason are
the same, by the way, if nobody knows
that. Um, Mormonism, too, just to throw
that in there. But we're specifically
pointing out Catholicism, that
double-headed phoenix that we were
talked about yesterday. That's a
Catholic symbol, or it's a Freemason
symbol, but you see it in Catholicism.
You see the allseeing eye. Uh, you see
all kinds of symbols actually on the on
the
Pope's hat, on his robe, uh, in the
buildings. I mean, it's it's all so in
your face. Symbols rule the world, and
when you know what you're looking for,
it's a universal language. You'll see it
all around the world. These same symbols
just like you're talking about. Even
Yeah. Even this rusta is on his on his
m. Yeah. Crazy, dude. Which is sun
worship straight up. Yeah. Yeah. Left is
Napoleon's father and on the right
Napoleon. Napoleon himself. What's going
on with the missing hand? Yeah. Why you
got your hand in your Would you grabbing
a gun or something? No, this is a this
is a Masonic hand sign. And these people
are just like uh gang members, you know.
They they show their allegiance by
showing a little hand sign just like you
know gangs are like Westside bro or
whatever. That's what these people do.
They flash their allegiance.
Yeah. And uh if you go to the next slide
Oh, wow.
Uh uh did we miss the memo?
M wow. How many of these people I mean
you see Pope Francis, you see uh uh what
is it? Mussolini. You see uh the the the
whole family of uh the the the the the
king the and his sons doing the sign
next to this guy's got the horns as
well.
Yeah. You see uh Obama doing it. You see
uh also the
uh chinpin yingpin whatever China guy in
the right corner. Uh so it's everywhere.
Somebody somebody in the comments said I
don't think Catholicism is Freemasonry.
I think Freemasonry just took over and
now run Catholicism. But
I don't know. It's the opposite. Uh it's
it's well Catholicism started with
Constantine.
Yeah. I mean Freemasonry is just it's
just uh uh it's controlled by the by the
Jesuits. So right uh and at the end of
the day uh both both uh belief systems
are the same and they come both from uh
from S Solomon right and from so it's
it's the same it comes out of out of the
same same camp. So it's basically the
same thing. Yep. Satan just has a
different package for everything. But
this is the thing also. It's a store.
It's a how do you say it? It's it's not
storefront. It's a front a front
organization. That's what it is. The
Catholic church cannot do all these
things. Uh because then everybody points
to the Catholic Church, right? They
needs they they need front organizations
and Freemasonry is just one of those
front organizations.
Yep. Very true. That's what it is. Oh,
this more. No. Oh. Oh, celebrities. Oh,
I think I I think we missed the memo.
Yeah, you can't just This can't be a
coincidence all the time. Like, oh, my,
you know, the top half of my hand just
always gets cold or whatever. I'm just
always warming it up. It's the same the
same like the peekaboo club, right? They
go with one eye symbolism. It's the same
thing, right? This is fun to hide one
eye. It's such a cool pose. I don't
know. I I went to the eye doctor. I need
to hide my Come on, people.
Oh, there it is, though. So, this is
this this is what's going on. It's here.
You see the the Duncan's ritual of
Freemasonry.
And if you can read what what is
highlighted. I cannot I cannot read it,
but can you read it? The highlighted
text. So, it says, "And the Lord said
unto Moses, put now thine hand
into thy bosom."
and he put his hand in his bosom, and
when he took it out, behold, his hand
was
lepous. Uh, no more.
So, that's where this originated from.
And that's just Yeah. And and so they do
everything under a Christian disguise,
right? So that's why they have the
aprons. The the aprons are based off of
um when Adam and Eve sinned, God covered
them with aprons, all this stuff. Yeah.
They give you a Bible when you become a
Mason. The lamb. Yeah. Lamb skin. It's
made out of lamb skin. Skin, right? Yep.
It's lamb skin. And and that's what's so
confusing about it because when you join
the Freemasons, they give you a
Freemason Bible with that compass on
there with the G in there. And people
think that means God and he's the
architect, the grand architect. Um, but
once you stay in that system and pay
your dues and level up, you find out who
who that God is.
You know, it's funny that Bible uh you
know what page uh what page uh the the
Bible actually starts? No. What's up?
33. Oh my goodness. I I actually
actually was looking at one at a a used
bookstore here and I went live and was
flipping through it and yeah, the front
it has a lot of uh like questions and
answers and stuff section. Interesting.
It actually said, "What's the shape of
the earth?" And they said it was like an
oblong rectangle or something. That was
pretty interesting.
And then in the back, you see all kinds
of Egyptian gods and things like that,
right? They're like, "What is that doing
in the in in the Bible, right?" Right.
Very interesting.
So, here you see uh what Oh, yeah. We
talked about the image of the beast,
right? Yeah.
So, it's uh Basilica and then what is
the other ones? One of his of course is
the United States uh
um so let's see. Yeah, United States
Capital Dome, St. Capital Dome. Y St.
Paul's Dome and St. Peter's Dome.
Yeah. What's crazy is um
you know there's so so much
misconception about Bible prophecy and I
I used to believe this stuff too in 2012
that was really like a wakeup for me. I
I'd heard the Bible all my life but
mainly just kind of the core stories
Adam and Eve Noah's arc and all that
kind of stuff. Um, definitely had heard
of the mark of the beast and there's so
many movies and stuff you just think,
oh, the mark of the beast is a microchip
and one day they're going to enforce it
on everybody and all this. We talked
about some of that, how that can't be
true because if that were true, then man
could take away your salvation literally
by just capturing you and jamming a
microchip in your hand or in your head.
Boom, you're no long you're lost now.
Right? So, it it's not a microchip. It's
not even technology. It's about worship,
the beliefs of your mind and the actions
of your hands. Um, so an example,
Shadrach, Meshach, and Abedneo, they
refused to disobey God and bow down to
an image. They didn't believe it in
their mind and they wouldn't even do it
with the works of their hands. They
said, "Throw us into the fire." That's
so that's the kind of courage we need to
have in the last days. If any law
enforces worship that's contrary to God,
we have to stand on what God says. They
could have simply said, "Oh, we'll just
bow our bodies. You know, it doesn't
mean anything." They could have
compromised, but they knew not to do
that. In the last days, there's going to
be a forced system of worship. If you
believe in it because it looks so good
and it's all about coexist and a
revival, then you've taken it in the
head. And if you don't believe the
system, but you're like, "Look, I just
got to, you know, go to the universal
church every Sunday or else, you know,
my I'm going to go broke and my family's
going to starve." then you've taken in
the hand. But when it comes to like the
image of the
beast, a lot of people think that the
image of the beast is some kind of
uh they think it's AI. They think it's,
you know, I don't know, television or
whatever. Like, it's an image that comes
to life because Revelation is all
symbolic. There's not really a a harlot
sitting on a a seven-headed dragon.
There's not really a woman standing on
the moon clothed with the sun. It's all
symbolic. And the Bible tells us what
the symbols are, but we know that beasts
are kingdoms. And so if the first beast
is Rome and the second beast is America,
which that might be shocking, that's a
huge study. But it we know that the
second beast is going to make an image
to the first beast. An image just means
a replica or a mirror. Yeah. A copy.
Yeah. Yeah. A mirror image. So basically
the second beast, mirror kingdom. A
mirror kingdom, right? A mirror kingdom.
Uh a copy of the same kingdom. Yeah.
America. America. Uh so America is going
to build a system that's a mirror image
of Rome. And that's what we see. And you
you see it in the physical sense too
with the domes and the obelisks and all
the sun stuff. But you see it through
their laws. That's what it says. It'll
speak as a dragon. It'll be it'll be
like a lamb. It'll it'll look like a
lamb. It'll look like a Christian
nation, but it'll speak as a dragon,
which represents Satan andor
Rome. And yeah, man, it's so clear when
you see pictures like
this. Oh, yeah. So, here. Yeah. The bald
eagle is the national animal and a
prominent political symbol of freedom.
And the Romans used the eagle as a
symbol of strength and of their supreme
god Zeus. Zeus. Oh my goodness.
So you see the two there's a maltis
cross right there above the eagle head
which that was uh where right above the
eagle's head. Yeah. Yeah. Okay. Yeah.
The left one. Yeah. And in the American
eagle you see the the hexog above the
head of the eagle there. the six-pointed
star that a lot of people mistakenly
associate with Israel and David and all
kinds of stuff. There's nothing in the
Bible about a star, a symbol of a star
being a good thing, you know, only the
star remun, right? Yeah. Star Refund.
Yep. That wasn't good. No. And and think
about it. When you look in the sky,
stars don't look like that. They don't
have five points or six points or
whatever. They're just a glowing ball up
there. Um, I think the reason they're
even called a star is just to kind of
let our guard down. It's really not a
star at all. It's a It's a pentagram
means five points or five angles. And
hexag means six angles. And it's got the
word hex right there in there, which is
a an an occult, a curse.
Yeah. A spell, a curse. Yeah. Yeah.
That's crazy, man. Oh, then here uh the
Statue of Liberty, a gift from France
again. Again, France. Interesting. Uh in
1886 is is Libertas, the Roman goddess
of liberty. And you see the Freemason
logo on the plaque. That was a Freemason
that created it. And that uh that was
the gift from the Freemasons to the
Freemasons that were in the United
States that ruled the US basically,
right? So that's crazy. Do you have a
comparison in here of the statue? And
no. Uh yeah. No, no, I don't have you
already you already covered it, so I
don't be redundant in that. So, but here
you see uh the official website of uh
the the capital, right? Um and then if
you can read the the highlighted one and
oh, but well, one moment on the on the
top uh here it says one second. Uh the
statue of uh freedom, freedom's crested
helmet and sword suggesting she is
prepared to protect the nation are more
commonly associated with
Manurva or Bel Bona uh Roman goddess of
war. Wow. Yeah. When we were in we were
in Washington, they openly sold
merchandise of Manurva. It's crazy.
So it says here the highlight of Texas.
Yeah. Yeah. The first one here says she
holds a laurel wreath of victory. The
laurel wreath is an a cult symbol too.
Uh e pluribus unum out of many one out
of many one. The lower part of the
pedestal is decorated with um fasces.
That's the That's that axe with the big
fat uh bamboo around it or
whatever. Symbols of the authority of
government and wreaths. So they got the
fascist and the wreaths. And then the
third one says the statue of
freedom crested helmet and sword
suggesting she is preparing to protect
the nation and more commonly associated
with Manurva or Balona Milana Roman
goddess of war. Oh yeah, that was that
was the one that I mentioned already.
Yep. Wow, dude. And then uh yeah, it's
crazy, man. It's and that's an official
website, right? So yeah, I can't make
this stuff up, right? You can see it's
right there from um from Architect of
the Capital or something like that.
Yeah, I've seen that website. It is the
official one. Yeah, we used that last
time when we did uh uh the second
episode or so. It's first and second
episode.
Uh the visionary behind this American
Rome was Francis Pope uh who acquired
the land on June 5th, 1663. His story
detailed in an October 7th, 1883
Washington Post article reflects a blend
of ambition and whimsy. Pope took uh
pride in his estate, often boasting
about his Rome on the tber. His unique
naming scheme wasn't just a personal
quirk. It was a statement of cultural
identity and historical awareness.
Interesting that it was also in Mary
land, right?
uh adding the uh to the narrative's
richness uh is the modern coincidence
between the air quotes uh of Pope
Francis the first American pope I mean
Latin American but sharing a name with
Francis Pope yeah American American
you've got North and South and South
America this time this this case uh
sharing a name with Francis Pope this
twist in the story connects the
historical and
contemporary worlds. It adds a layer of
irony and depth bridging centuries of
history through a shared name.
Coincidence? Think twice.
I mean that last word I added. But yeah,
isn't it crazy? And uh I mean
it's all roads lead to Rome. Yep. Oh,
okay. This is what you were talking
about.
Yeah, this is what I was talking about.
This is crazy. This song, I missed this.
I never I didn't see this. Uh Elon Musk
with a chainsaw, but this is
like the movie Oh, what is that movie?
Idiocracy. Yeah. No, the movie Idiocracy
where presidential candidates is all
about like who's the wildest and
coolest. It's like there's a pro
wrestler guy that comes out and he's
like got machine guns and stuff. I mean
this is nuts. Like you got to think
realistically about it's a show, man.
This is a show. I mean Yeah. This is pro
wrestling all the way.
Yeah. Like we're we're choosing the
leaders of our country, the kings, and
you got these guys wearing sunglasses
and
chainsaws. It's so ridiculous. Yeah.
It's insane. So on the right side you
see uh clearly the one that is uh
pulling the strings right with the
Godfather, the marionette on the right
side. On the left side this uh it's it's
left out. Uh but make no mistake, Elon
pulls the AI strings for you. That's
right.
And and and I just wrote honor it like
however it's going back to the mafia
boss. We talked about the mafia
partially of uh you know part of the
whole noble uh black nobility the the
and and the ties to the mafia and
ultimately the the Catholic church.
So that's interesting about references
back right. Yeah that's interesting
about doge being egod or electronic
god like yeah like email and stuff. I
forgot I forgot I Oh yeah I forgot that
one. Yeah, those spelled backwards.
EGOD, Elon Got or electronic God. I
mean, again, it's a it's a play with the
word. Well, that's what he said. He said
um Yeah. Well, he he said um in that
interview with Jordan Peterson, he's
like, "Well, maybe AI will be our next
god." And he was laughing and stuff and
and Jordan Peterson was like, "Uh, yeah,
that's not funny." But AI is the
electronic god, Doge. And he he came e
and made it Doge backwards. Interesting.
And you know what do also means? Yeah, I
know it's a dog. Let's go to the next
slide. Okay. Yeah, let's go to the next
slide. Oh,
uh doge of uh is this the first or
no one? Okay, there we go. Yeah. Uh the
doge of
Venice and one second here. uh was the
dose of highest role of authority within
the republic again republic right of fis
the word doze derives from the latin
duks meaning leader and phoenian Italian
for duke highest official of the
republic of fenis for over thousand
years originally referencing of
referring to any military leader
becoming uh becoming in a late Roman
empire the title for a leader
of an extra uh extra no expeditionary
force formed by detachments
uh from the frontier army uh separate
for from from but subject to the
governor of a province authorized to
conduct operations beyond provincial
boundaries. The Doge of Venice acted as
both the head of state and head of the
Phoenician oligarchy.
uh doas were elected for life through a
complex voting process. Interesting.
It took it its later uh and more
magnificent form after the visit to
Venice in 1177 of Pope Alexander III and
the Holy Roman Emperor Frederick
uh first. On state occasions, the doge
was surrounded by an increasing an
increasing amount of ceremony and in
international relations, he had the
status of a sovereign prince. What do we
see with Elon Musk?
Um, comparison is just is bizarre,
right? So, it's saying that basically
Doge is like a Roman
soldier and no, more like a Roman uh a
Roman uh ruler under under the the
official
um governor, right? Or the under the a
duke basically, right? Under the um the
rulership of of the king or the
Yeah. Wow, dude. That is so nuts. And
so, yeah, it says that they are voted
for a life.
Where did I see that? Voted for life. I
don't remember where it was at now.
That's Yeah, voting process. Doas were
elected for life through a complex
voting process. And what do we got? We
got Trump saying, "If you vote for me
once, that's all it'll take."
third term. Yeah. And oh my goodness, I
just don't even
understand who Elon is right now. Like
what is his
position? Just best friend of the
president and he's he's the under king.
Yeah. Whatever. Some people think that
some people think that Elon is basically
the president and I don't know.
Crazy stuff, man. They're all act
They're all actors, right? Actors, man.
When you live in a world where you can't
even tell who's who anymore, it's just
like, yeah, it's all a show, man.
Then the dose of Genanoa is another one
was the head of state uh of the Republic
of Genanoa, a city state and soon
afterwards a maritin republic from 1339
until the state's ex extinction in 1797.
Originally elected for life after 1528,
the doers were elected for terms of two
years. Huh? Two years. Two years. Hey,
two years. Where do we see that here?
Oh, we said if you're in the United
States, you're elected for two years.
Oh, no. Two. Oh, no. Okay. Four years.
Four years. Okay. That's not the same.
But it's the same kind of system. It's
like voting for a a certain time span
and then there's another election. It's
not like a king thing going on. Correct.
Yeah. Two years. I was thinking about
two terms, but no, that's two years.
Okay. Uh, the republic or do was ruled
by a small group of merchant families.
Merchants. Hey.
Merchants he's a merchant right or the
rich men of the earth from whom the
doers were selected so yeah from the
rich from the the the business people of
the those were selected so that's
interesting the comparisons are just
amazing Elon is the richest man on earth
now
officially that's crazy
dude wow yeah he was not even elected
No. So uh despite the great power given
to them, the Phoenician doers were
restricted by law unlike of the
republicans you know to spend the rest
of their lives inside the Doj's palace
complex and St. Mark's St. Mark's
Basilica right occasionally leaving the
diplomatic reasons for diplomatic
reasons. So St. Mark's Basilica shows
you where the allegiance lies, right?
Because that is what if you go to the
next slide.
Yeah. St. Mary's Basilica denomination
Catholic Church.
Everything.
So what is it saying here?
So this palace complex. Oh the doge.
The palace complex and St. Mark's
Basilica. There's both, right? So, so
this is this is giving more evidence to
what Doge represents and who the Doge is
associated with the Catholic Church and
all that.
I mean, in Italy back then, but you
know, of a coin named after it, the
image.
Yeah.
It's crazy, man.
It's so uh this is very lengthy so we
can cut it off at some point in within
uh five minutes or so. This is uh uh
showing you who Marina Abraim Abramovic
is. Okay. Uh and uh after that we're
going to go into like what she's saying
about Donald Trump. Okay. Just give me a
little flag me or something when you
think. Okay. Gaga's close friend,
Crowleyian Satanist Marina Abramovich,
was catapulted to infamy as the subjects
of the most bizarre of the Wikileak
revelations, tying Hillary Clinton's
campaign chairman, John Podesta, and the
highest echelons of government to
Satanist organizer Aler Crowley and his
satanic sex magic cult. Abramovich,
quite like Gaga, likes to dress up like
a witch and to adorn herself with goats
heads and devil horns and all sorts of
satanic symbolism. Gaga's close friend
Abramovich said, quote, "My mother
dressed me as a devil when I was four
years old for a party. I have no idea
why she dressed me as a devil. I think
to mark my life." End quote. According
to Wikileaks, Abramovich invited
Hillary's campaign chairman, John
Podesta, to her home for a satanic
spirit cooking dinner as though it was a
routine practice. This gives us
incredible insight into the satanic
practices of the political elite at the
highest echelons of government. Some of
Wikileaks statements regarding the
revelation stated, quote, "Tony Podesta
by day, mildmannered foreign agent for
Saudi Arabia, by night, spirit cooker."
Or, "The Podesta is a spirit cooking
dinner. It's not what you think. It's
blood, sperm, breast milk, but mostly
blood." And yet another Wikileak, quote,
"Podesta participated in potentially
satanic spirit cooking." In an email
revealed by Wikileaks in June of 2015 by
Abramovich to John Podesta's brother
Tony Podesta, Gaga's close friend
Abramovich wrote, quote, "I am so
looking forward to the spirit cooking
dinner at my place. Do you think you
will be able to let me know if your
brother is joining? All my love,
Marina." Tony Podesta forwarded the
email to his brother, John Podesta,
asking, "Are you in New York City
Thursday, July 9th? Marina wants you to
come to dinner." End quote. What is John
Podesta? Hillary Clinton's campaign
chairman at the time and a high-ranking
member of the DNC doing hanging out with
Satanists and being invited to their
rituals. You can't make this stuff up,
folks. The satanic ritual, which Podesta
was expected to attend, as you shall
see, if done according to Satanist
Alistister Crowley's book of the law,
which Abramovich appears to be largely
following, involves child
sacrifice. Most everyone missed the
child sacrifice connection with spirit
cooking. We know that Abramovich was
using much of Crowley's spirit cooking
recipe for devil worshippers because she
documented this for us in a video where
you can see her writing down many of the
ingredients for spirit cooking. Gaga has
spent much time praising the satanic
spirit cooker Abramovich, even claiming
her influence on her life. Marina, I
think you are so wonderful, so beautiful
and inspiring and and as a woman, I am
want to translate what her work means
into my own life on a on a domestic
level. I am obsessed with this woman.
She is so incredible. The satanic spirit
cooking ritual is better known as the
cake of light ritual among Crowley
Satanists and is like a blasphemous
satanic sacrament practiced by Crowley's
Oto members that mocks Jesus's last
supper of partaking of unleaven bread in
remembrance of Jesus's love and death
for the sins of the world to deliver
them from hell. As you can see, she also
uses Crowian symbols like the triangle
and the number of the antichrist 666.
All of this is quite revealing as to
what many of these people in the higher
echelons of politics and the
entertainment world are all about. We
also see here that Abramovich appears to
really love the number of the beast as
her Twitter handle is Abramovich
M666. Wow. The cake of light ritual was
created by Crowley and conducted as part
of Crowley's Gnostic mass ritual where
quote a small flat wafer end quote is
used and made out of honey oil and
bodily excrements like menstrual blood,
breast milk, urine and sperm. In chapter
20 of Crowley's book, Magic and Three
and Practice, a footnote on the contents
when discussing spirit cooking includes
procuring the flesh blood of an animal.
According to Crowley, quote, "The subtle
principle of animal life itself is fixed
in them by the introduction of fresh
living blood." End quote. In
Abramovich's video, she claims that she
used pig's blood. Crowley and Satanist
often take the devil's supper every day
as the most important of Crowley's
satanic sacraments to be fully possessed
by the devil. Crowley taught in his
magic book four, quote, "A Eucharist of
some sort should most assuredly be
consummated daily by every magician, and
he should regarded as the main
sustenance of his magical life, is of
more importance than any other magical
ceremony, because it is a complete
circle." End quote. Abramovich's
perspective spirit cooking dinner with
Hillary Clinton's campaign chairman John
Podesta reveals she is no mere neopight
to Crowleyian Satanism as she writes on
a wall in blood the Crowian recipe for
the ritual. Mix fresh breast milk with
fresh sperm. Fresh morning urine
sprinkle over nightmare dreams with a
sharp knife cut deeply into your middle
finger. Eat the pain. End quote.
According to Crowley's satanic cult, a
batch of the sacrificial meal could make
up to 50 or more cakes. Abramovich
appears to make something similar to the
cake of light. Here she is seen with her
friend and fellow occult practitioner,
popular actor James Franco, who she
instructs to close his eyes as he eats a
special cake covered with gold. Eat it
slowly and just really feel the texture
and the taste.
In her video that she herself calls
spirit cooking, we see a few seconds
where she cuts to a clip of her wrapped
up by a serpent. As we shall see, this
imagery reveals the main purpose of
spirit cooking. Lady Gaga, Abramovich,
John Podesta, and James Franco seems
like birds of a satanic feather flock
together. Franco was seen here in a
video for his song Love in the Old Days
wherein he directs a satanic wedding
which is officiated by his good friend
Satanist Kenneth Anger who co-founded
the Church of Satan. In the video,
subliminal pictures of Satanist Alleser
Crowley flash across the screen.
Apparently, Abramovich's planned dinner
with Podesta was not merely art. As
Brahovich admitted in an online
interview when asked about Crowley's
magic spelled with a K, she stated,
quote, "Everything depends on which
context you are doing what you are
doing. If you are doing the occult magic
in the context of art or in a gallery,
then it is the art. If you are doing it
in a different context in spiritual
circles or a private house, eg Podesta
and her, or on TV shows, it is not art.
The intention, the context of what is
made and where it is made defines what
art is or not. End quote. As wicked and
as evil as the satanic cake of light
ritual is, the spirit cooking ritual
becomes all the more sinister when we
read from Al Crowley himself that the
blood is to be procured at least in part
from a child's sacrifice. In Crowley's
book of the law, he gives evil and
twisted instructions in regard to the
ingredients of spirit cooking, which he
claimed were dictated to him by a spirit
entity named Iwas, whom he identifies in
other writings as Satan himself. In the
so-called cakes of light, which are at
the heart of Abramovich's spirit dinner,
Satanists are instructed to provide
quote rich fresh blood, then the fresh
blood of a child end quote. We read that
Satan instructed Crowley Satanists in
the book of the law after instructing to
use rich fresh blood that quote the best
blood is of the moon monthly. Speaking
of course of menstrual blood, then the
fresh blood of a child or dropping from
the host of heaven, then of enemies,
then of priests or of worshippers. Last
of some beast, no matter what this burn
of this, make cakes and eat unto me. End
quote. This is a reference to the spirit
that is channeling Crowley wanting
worship from child sacrifice. A
sacrifice that Abramovich and John
Podesta and who knows how many others
potentially practice. Incredibly, in
Abramovich's spirit cooking video, we
see her bring an effigy of a child that
she puts near the wall with the other
ingredients as part of the spirit
cooking dinner. She then proceeds to
splash the child effigy with blood. Wow.
The demonic entity that identified
itself as Satan to Crowley demanded to
be worshiped by the sacrifice of
children repeatedly. The book of the law
commands, quote, "Worship me with fire
and blood. Worship me with swords and
spears. Let blood flow in my name. I
will give you their flesh to eat.
Sacrifice cattle after a child. Kill and
torture. Spare not be upon them." End
quote. Crowley wrote much about
sacrificing children to Satan and
instructs initiates in his book magic
and theory and practice to engage in
child sacrifice. He stated, quote, "A
male child of perfect innocence and high
intelligence is the most satisfactory
and suitable victim. But the bloody
sacrifice, though more dangerous, is
more efficacious, and for nearly all
purposes, human sacrifice is the best."
End quote. Here we see Lady Gaga and her
good friend Crowleyian satanic spirit
cooker Marina Brahmovich participating
in a very disturbing blood eating
simulation. Abramovich seems to have a
real strange fascination with blood
sacrifice and even cannibalism. Here we
see her walking around one of her
so-called art shows where cakes are
formed into human bodies and then eaten.
Different celebrities appear with
throughout this show including Blondie
and Gwen Stefani. Of course, Lady Gaga
is not the only one that Abramovich has
had such a strong influence on. She has
also influenced the music of Jay-Z. The
deeper meaning behind the spirit cooking
ritual, which was also revealed in
Abramovich's video, was missed by pretty
much everyone. The purpose is to realize
one's supposed divinity and become one
with the spirit of Satan, hence the term
spirit cooking. Crowley taught the lie
that Satan told Eve in Eden and the lie
of the Antichrist that man can become
God. Crowley stated that the result of
spirit cooking is quote by day matter is
replaced by spirit, the human by the
divine. Ultimately, the change will be
complete. God manifest in the flesh will
be his name. End quote. However, the
reality is one becomes more and more at
one with the devil and shares his
eternal destiny in the lake of fire.
Abramovich's video on spirit cooking
after listing on a wall some of the
ingredients of the cake of light and
even more disturbing splashing an effigy
of a small child with blood.
Abramovich's video cuts to a clip of a
huge snake wrapping around her body.
This underscores the satanic goal of the
spirit cooking ritual. Invoking the
serpent of old, a biblical symbol for
the devil. Abramovich is simply
declaring that spirit cooking makes you
one with the devil. Crowley's book of
the law states that the world is to be
ruled by a group of satanic elite
supermen under the authority of the
beast or the antichrist and Satan. The
book of the law states, quote, "Let my
servants be few and secret. They shall
rule the many and the known." End quote.
Through the Wikileaks revelations, we
received a rare window into how some of
Satan's apparent servants like John
Podesta and Marina Abramovich are
worshiping him in secret. Satanist
Marina Abramovich was officially invited
to Hillary's campaign launch at Franklin
D. Roosevelt for Freedoms Park at
Roosevelt Island in New York City. It
was at the same park that Hillary
Clinton's husband, Bill Clinton,
revealed that Hillary was still
receiving spirit messages from spirit
entities via what Hillary claims to be
Elanar Roosevelt. And according to Bill
Clinton, she claimed that she had
received a fresh revelation for the
audience at the park. My wife, now the
Secretary of
State, was known to commune with Eleanor
on a regular basis. What?
And so she called me last night on her
way home from Peru to remind me to say
that that Eleanor had talked to her and
reminded her that I should say that.
Whoa.
Wow. I'm glad we watched that because we
we watched the whole thing. Yeah. I was
like, all play out. Oh my goodness.
again again it's like uh become God.
It's uh it's it's it's all the same lie
uh let the let the the the elite uh be
few and and you
know bizarre. Shout out to Good Fight
Ministries. They did some great work on
that. Um I actually never seen that one.
And it looks like a newer video, but
they dude, they really just broke down
so much of this. And the fact that Bill
Clinton was saying openly that Hillary
communes with the dead. Yeah, we we are
controlled by spiritist. And that's what
we know is coming in the last days. We
know that it's going to be uh
spiritualism and Sunday sacredness or
sun worship in general. And I didn't
know that Alistister Crowley said that
stuff. And this chick's
having parties with I I knew that
Hollywood was there. I didn't know that
they were so open about the the
politics, the political leaders being
involved with her. Super in your face.
Blatant stuff, man. Wow. Here's another
clip with her. Want to run this? Yeah.
Yep. Yep. Let's let's let's show the
people what what she thinks about Trump.
All right. You know, I just want to
share with you one really funny opinion,
but there is a in Lapland there is a
group of the the shamans there who do
something called collective dreaming.
They will go together in seclusion and
do the rituals with the you know eating
very little food and being in a in in
solitude for a long time and they will
go and dream the dreams and the dream
have to be called it same dream. So
coming out of this dream this once the
shaman told me that actually the best
thing happened this in this planet right
now is the Trump to be the president. I
said how is this possible is the best
thing to happen. He say yes because
because he's so irrational he's so crazy
that's actually create that wakening
that we finally wake up because before
it will be another guy and another guy
and everything looks similar but he's so
different than anything else. So the
actually he's the the magician who wked
us up. What you think about
that? That kind of theory,
dude. Uh she's talking about Trump,
right?
Yeah, she talks about Trump.
Oh my goodness, dude. And she, you know,
she's going by Alistister Crowley's
playbook for the rulers of the world
need to be Satanist. And she's like,
"Oh, this is great. We got Trump and Oh,
and by Yeah. Well, and by the way, um
also it reminded me um Lady Gaga was
saying, "Oh, she's the best thing in the
world and blah blah blah." And uh
remember that you did a video on on the
SNL, right? That's right.
And and you see again what did Abra say?
Uh or what did they what do they say? If
it's on TV, it's a ritual, right? Yeah.
Yeah, dude. Openly. They they tell you
that, man. It's And so it's a ritual.
It's not art. Yeah. And um at that
spirit cooking party was Will Frell.
Will Frell was on Saturday Night Live.
So, you know, Satan loves to use comedy
to let people's guard down and to make
us even laugh at the most vile things,
whether it's adultery, Satanism, murder.
I mean, you just put a laugh track on
anything and suddenly people are
laughing at the most sadistic
things and that's the best way to make
it palatable or accepted by the masses.
And you know, Will Frell, he's dressed
up as Satan and playing playing guitar
and um trying to convince Gar Brooks to
sell his soul to him for music and stuff
like that. They they've done so much of
this stuff. It's crazy.
Yeah. What do we got here? Is this a
video? Next one is Yeah, this video is
the same. It's the same uh uh Abramovich
telling the kind of the same story, but
a little bit uh other context maybe. So,
I just wanted to show you that it's not
one occasion that she's telling this,
it's more occasions that she's saying
this. So, you can roll roll this video.
But look at these two guys, Trump with
the Kim Jong Kim Jong. They're two
lunatics. completely horrible human
beings, corrupted and and
and you know we don't we don't like them
because there lots of good reasons not
to like them. I just talked to the last
I was in Rome two days ago in Rome and I
met one shaman woman from the north of
um Norway. So this woman told me three
days ago that the trap is the best thing
happened ever to
us because she believed not her but the
entire you know population of this
Nordic magician that he is the magician
of the highest order that he is there in
his irrational mind to create confusion
in order that the human being can find
new order and you know it's not so
stupid thinking about this in that way.
It's completely turning things upside
down. Uhhuh. Because since Trump is
around, things are
changing because we are waking up.
[Music]
That's it. Dude, that is
She said she was in Rome and a shaman
told her that Trump is the best thing to
happen. What has Rome got to do with
Trump? She's in Rome. I know. She was in
Rome. Insane, right? Well, yeah. Why Why
would Why would anybody in Rome have
anything highest order? Yeah, dude. And
he and he uses MAGA. I don't know if
you're going to talk about that, but
Make America Great Again. You do? Yeah.
Okay. The connections. We're going into
that. Wow, dude. We're going into that,
man. Yeah. This is crazy. This is some
pictures uh all the celebrities. Uh they
have the Manson Gaga.
Yeah.
Is that a Who is this?
Who is that?
Bill Clinton. Oh, it looked like some
kind of priest with that sash or
something. No, no, no. He That's Bill
Clinton. And then Gwen Stefani, right?
Uh oh, I thought Oh, you mean the
Christian that was pushing lint? Yeah.
Oh my goodness. Yeah, I've seen her
eating the cake and stuff. Dude, we
cannot fall for That's the thing, man.
In these last days, it's going to be so
deceptive. You cannot just fall for
anybody that says, "I'm a Christian."
Especially if they're promoting
Catholicism and uh and
eating bodies, you know, cakes that look
like bodies and stuff.
Crazy. Uh guest audio mic needs to come
up. I wish I could control that.
Somebody's saying your your microphone's
not as loud.
Oh, okay. Speak a little
louder. Um, speak a little louder. Speak
a little louder. Try. Oh, there's
Lucifer's cross or Leviathan's cross,
the cross of Satan there.
Yeah. The church of Satan.com. You see
it on top. And the hierarchy in the
church of Satan. So, uh, uh, so the
administration, can you read what the
administration? You see the it's Alto L
right? Uh yeah Magus Maga. Yeah Mag
Magus
Anton le founder. So Maggus. Oh
interesting because a magi or magician.
Yeah. Yeah. Right here. Maga on the
right side. Yeah means witch.
So maga means witch. Let's see. Maga in
Latin. And
Yeah. And MAGA is the fifth degree, the
highest degree in the church of Satan.
That's the hierarchy down there where
your arrow is. Wow, dude. No, that that
thing there. Yeah, it says MAGA, right?
And Magnus, fifth degree. Fifth degree.
It's the high that's the highest degree
in the Church of Satan. That's crazy,
dude. And yeah, and she's saying he's a
witch of the highest degree. And he's
got everybody, all the Republicans that
all the Republicans that think they're
voting for a Christian and standing for
a Christian nation are all saying MAGA
and wearing the hat and all that.
Nuts, dude. Insane. So uh this is not
the first time that uh uh Make America
Great Again has been uh coined. Ronald
Reagan coined actually Make America
Great Again.
And Bill Clinton also used uh used it
and uh oh he met both of them. Of course
he was friends with them both. So it
doesn't matter if you're left or right,
red or blue, Republican or Democrat, you
still got MAGA.
Yeah.
Wow, dude. This is nuts.
Yep.
The Baron Trump novels. So Oh, the Baron
Trump. Okay. Yeah. So there there used
there's a a novel uh from uh from where
the the year 1889 or so it says it's a
little a little small but 1889
uh and basically about uh uh Trump being
the last president and um it's insane
this it's kind of like they call it the
Trump prophecy the book right uh and he
the the guy the guy is on on uh uh it's
about Baron Trump and he's on living on
Fifth venue. Where does Trump live? Oh,
yeah. On Fifth Avenue, right? So, it's
Yeah, it's crazy. Um, we actually did a
show with uh Josh from Founded Earth
Brothers and he he went into that a
little bit. I can't remember. I think it
was the Elon one. If you look in in our
live shows and you see Elon and it says
a star is born, goes into a little more
detail showing some pages on that.
Everything's tying in, dude. It's so
cool. That one, too. Oh, you got it. We
I think or in this one or next another
one, but yeah, I think I heard in this
one. Okay, so here we see Melania Trump.
Melania Canals Trump is a is a Slovenian
and American former model who is the
first lady of the United States since
2025 as wife of President Donald Trump.
She is the second Catholic first lady
after Jacqueline Kennedy, wife of John
F. Kennedy. Donald's fame and
connections gave her uh new career
opport opportunities. Shortly after the
death of Jacqueline Jacqueline Kennedy,
whom Melania and her mother had deeply
admired, uh Melania met met the Kennedy
family at a gala. She continued to
encounter se celebrities while attending
events with Donald. Wow. So first she's
the second Catholic uh first lady and
there there's connection there with the
with the can Kennedy family from long
time ago. Yeah. Because if you go to the
next
slide, if you go to the next slide here,
you see um uh that that she lived from
uh what is it? 1961.
Um oh, let's see. Yeah. What is it? Yep.
1961 to
1963. Oh, that was how she was she was
in roll there.
Oh. Oh. Oh. In the role. No. Um. Oh.
When did she pass? There was there was
somewhere that uh I don't know when she
passed, but she knows him about she
knows uh the the Kennedys for a long
long time. She she passed away. Mhm. Uh
oh, here it is. Here it is. She she
passed away in 1994. So, wow. Before
1994, Melania was already befriended
with the Kennedy family. Wow, that's so
interesting. Before she was even second
lady or first lady or whatever.
Correct. Correct. So, isn't it
interesting then that uh RFK now is in
is is in the White House is the
connection there. Yeah. It's not the
connection is not new. Wow, man. And
here on the right side you see uh
Melania and Trump of course visiting the
pope with the pope. Yeah. What what is
dude for any logical rational thinking
person what does American president have
to do with the pope? Why do they all fly
over there and see the pope? Makes no
sense. Submission. Submission. You know
what? Uh what color is she wearing?
Black. All black. A veil. Yeah, she's in
black and she wears a veil. That's
submission.
And this is funny. This is funny because
normally uh in the Middle East all the
women are what? Car having a a burka,
right? Have the head covered. Yeah. Uh
when she when she went to Saudi Arabia
with Donald Trump, she didn't wear
anything.
Her hair just open in the open. And now
with the with the with the pope, she
covered her hair, right? So she's not
just conforming to culture and being
respectful. This is something
specifically
um submitting to him. Yeah.
And in black, right? So yeah.
So here you see uh oh this is
interesting. John uh George Trump uh was
an American electrical engineer uh phys
physicist and inventor.
um and he was the professor at the at
MIT and uh basically what happens was um
he
um he received what was it now um oh no
no no okay so Trump uh was the brother
of Fred
Trump the John G Trump right uh Donald
Trump's father so there were he was the
brother of Donald Trump's father and in
early 1943 Three. Two days after the
death of Nicola Tesla, the federal bure
of investigation FBI ordered the office
of Allen property custodian seize
Tesla's
alien. Oh yeah. To seize Tesla's
belongings. Trump was called in in to
analyze the Tesla artifacts which were
being held in government custody. After
a three-day investigation, Trump's
report concluded that none of the
artifacts would constitute a hazard in
unfriendly hands.
But now we have his little um nephew in
office. And who is uh his right-wing
man? Oh yeah. No, no. Go back. Go back.
Go back. Go back. Yeah. Elon Musk,
right? Yeah. And what what does he
represent? Tesla. He's the man of Tesla,
Nicola. So, there's the Tesla
connection.
It's interesting. Wow.
So, next slide.
Here you see uh Trump's pastor Norman
Vincent Pe was a 33rd degree Freemason.
Yeah. Here is in this picture here,
Donald Trump is a Mason in a Masonic
temple with his pastor below. Wow, dude.
That's crazy. You tell me. Yeah, there's
a lot of people that are in denial that
Trump is a Freemason, but you don't get
to this level of wealth and especially
presidency without becoming one. You
just don't you don't become part of part
of the club unless you're part of the
club.
Nope. No. Nope. So, yeah. Norman Vincent
Peele uh he was a he is kind of like he
was the Joel Ostein from from that day
right so he was preaching the same kind
of positive thinking message just like
Joel oh yeah up here the power of
positive thinking 1952
and and basically the law of attraction
right that's like the same idea exactly
it doesn't say the power of idea yeah it
doesn't say the power of scripture or
the power of God's promises it says the
power of posit Positive thinking.
Wow. Yeah. Think it in your mind and and
will it long enough. And this is
interesting. This is his son, Donald
Trump Jr., right? Posting this picture.
Trump looking in the mirror and seeing a
goat. Well, uh, if you look at the right
side, you see Baffomet the goat, right?
Yeah. Why would you post this, man?
Why? Yeah. And he's like goat. You know,
everybody's going to defend that and say
that means greatest of all time. Dude,
the whole thing is where does where do
these sayings come from? You know, all
these
um slangs
and trendy things, they all come from
the elites, the celebrities. They're the
ones that if they wear that thing, they
say that thing, they do that thing, now
all of a sudden you do it. We imitate
pop culture. That's why we imitate lines
from movies and our favorite celebrities
and all that stuff. It's it's a form of
idolatry. It's a form of but but but but
a picture on itself, right? If we only
show this picture and say, "Oh, go and
make this connection, right? Okay, I
understand that that that's far-fetched,
right? But we have a case here. We for
three four episodes now, we've we've
gathered so much information." Yeah.
about Donald Trump and all everything
together, it all comes comes to the same
conclusion. Uh it it adds up, right? The
the the the scale uh is is uh is is
leading all the way to the bottom,
right? SpaceX had a a goat logo, too. I
don't know if you remember that. Oh, I
didn't know that. Let me see if if it's
possible for me to find it real quick.
SpaceX and goat. Okay, let me see if I
can share this.
Is that showing up? Okay. Images. Yeah,
it shows.
Oh, wow. That's on the window he has
back there.
And let's see. And and and oh, if if you
look at that logo, uh it was even a a
cross downwards.
We're at see that. Oh, yeah. Yeah,
exactly. X, but it's also cross
downwards. Yep. Sure is.
Um, wow. So, yeah. See? Oh, I didn't
mean to click that.
Um, yeah. See, he has this. And there's
there's another lo. Oh, yeah. This, too.
I forgot about this. The the statue of
Elon as a goat riding. It says Elon
Goat. It's a golden idol of Elon as a
goat. It's all just coincidence, though,
bro. I mean,
yeah. All acquaintance, man. Quinkkey
dink. You're just looking too deep, man.
You're just trying to make connections
that aren't there. One of their I wish I
could find it. One of his uh SpaceX
logos upside down made a goat. Let me
see. Upside down. And I want you to look
up one more thing in a second. Um Oh,
yeah. Oh. Oh, yeah. We forgot about this
too, right? Yeah. So, I mean, I forgot
this one. Oh, man. You're reaching. On
the back of this is Yeah. On the back
there's a uh on the back side there was
an upside down cross. Yeah. On the
forehead of this thing. What What do you
want us to find? You want to look up
something? Yeah. Uh if she if she if she
look up uh uh uh uh gold hoof
gold hoof goat goat monologu
um
uh gold gold golden golden so golden
golden
uh
goat or
No. Um, Mara Lago. Maro. Marago. Mar. M.
No. No. No. No. Mar. M A R. Oh.
Oh, I see it. Algo. Yep. What is this?
This.
What is this? Click on it and zoom in on
it. This This is a goat in Maraago. Oh.
With money.
Uh, money on it. And in Trump we trust,
it says. Oh my goodness, dude. What is
this? Okay, fact
check. Fact check. Goat covered in $100
Trump bills is on display at Mara Mara
Lago. Whatever that is. I'm not sure
what that is. True. Even Snopes. Okay,
just to let you know, Snopes is like
they hate conspiracy theories. They'll
do anything to debunk a conspiracy
theory and they said it's
true. Yeah. Does it say in Trump we
trust you know and and and
golden hood? It says there the patriot
takes. Dude, what is up with these
people are like completely obsessed idol
worshippers. It literally says the
idol's base. Yeah, it says here the
idol's base says I love you along with
Trump's signature.
Um that says in Trump we trust. See that
in trumpet trust. Man, why do they keep
calling it an idol? They act like like
this isn't even a negative post. They're
just like No, I know. The goat idol. The
idol is wrapped in This is the thing,
but but but this is the thing. It's a
$100 bill, right? Yeah. Recently in the
in the news, uh look up in the news in
Google. Um look up $100 bill Donald
Trump.
So, let's see. The news says counterfeit
$100 bills featuring Trump seen
circulation. No, this on No, this on
Newsweek music. Donald Trump would
replace Benjamin Franklin $100 bill.
Donald Trump would what? This was March
2025. This was just days, less than a
month ago.
Yeah. Republican
lawmaker is introducing legislation to
immortalize President Donald Trump.
Okay, for
one, they call them dead presidents for
a reason. You don't get to be on the
dollar bill unless you're dead. And he's
still alive and they want to immortalize
him by putting him on the $100 bill.
Representative Brand Brandon Gil, who
represents Texas,
said he plans to introduce a bill to
feature Trump's likeness on a $100 note
once his current term concludes. Oh my
goodness,
dude. Why it
matters. The last time a US bank note
design changed in this way was in 1929
when President Andrew Jack Jackson
replaced President Grover Cleveland on
the $20 bill. The $100 bill has featured
Benjamin Franklin, a founding father
since
1914 when he was replaced on the first
Federal Reserve note in the denom. Oh my
goodness, dude. This is
insane. Wow. I know. Oh, it's Newsweek.
It's not It's not just a news site. It's
Newsweek, right? Yeah. It's not like
National Enquirer or something.
Wow, dude.
So,
the golden age of America has already
begun, right?
On the white the White House. Fifth
Swami. The dawn of a new golden age
starts on Monday. Oh, the golden age of
America. Are you going to go into like
what that means?
Yeah. Yeah, I'm going into that. Okay.
Correct.
So uh the pact romana in Latin uh Roman
peace is a roughly 200 year long period
of Roman history which is identified as
a golden age of increased and sustained
Roman imperialism relative peace uh and
order prosperous stability hegmonic
power and regional
expansion. That's what it means. Wow.
The golden
age.
Um, so it's about prosperity and stuff,
right? Prosperous, stability. Yeah.
Power.
And it's Roman. And And you're going to
have his face on the $100 bill. Crazy.
This is a video, by the way. Oh, okay.
Let me play it. Donald Trump calling on
the United States of America to take
over the Gaza Strip. And this is
something that they've had planned for a
long period of time, which goes into the
greater Israel, the expansion of Israel.
And of course, they're going to do this
by duping you into saying, "Well, Israel
is not really taking over Gaza. The
United States of America is taking over
Gaza." But it's one and the same, right?
Donald Trump tweeted out on his truth
social account and on his Twitter
account that the Gaza Strip would be
turned over to the United States by
Israel at the conclusion of fighting.
The Palestinians, people like Chuck
Schumer, would have already been
resettled in far safer and more
beautiful communities with new and
modern homes in the region. They would
actually have a chance to be happy,
safe, and free. The US, working with
great development teams from all over
the world, would slowly and carefully
begin the construction of what would
become one of the greatest and most
spectacular developments of its kind on
Earth. No soldiers by the US would be
needed. Stability for the region would
reign. And of course, you see how he
mixes in humor by calling Chuck Schumer
a Palestinian who couldn't be more of a
citizen of Israel. By saying things like
that, it takes attention off of what
he's really saying here. And what
everybody should be focusing on is how
he's talking about building out smart
city governance, a smart city
infrastructure. That's what he's saying
when he's talking about how it's going
to be the greatest and most spectacular
developments of its kind on earth. And
what they had to do was because this has
been the plan, right? This has been the
plan for the greater Israel is something
that's been blueprinted for a long time.
Like I mentioned in a previous video,
you could even see that specific map
worn on patches on Israeli soldiers
sleeves. Not the actual that would be
the equivalent of a United States
soldier instead of just having North
America on its patch on its arm having
North America, Mexico, Canada, and
Greenland on his patch. That might have
been a little bit too obvious in America
if our American soldiers have been
wearing that for the past decade or so.
But nobody seemed to notice that over in
Israel. So what they had to do to bring
this plan in was obviously just bomb the
area, turn it into ashes. And anybody
that was in the way was a casualty for
the greater good. Because remember
that's how these Satanists and these
secret societies think. They don't care
if you're in the way. It's for the
greater good. Us demolishing your home,
it's for the greater good. Build back
better. Right? So they commit these
atrocities so that they can bring in
this smart city. Last year, last year,
Netanyahu talked about his vision for
Gaza in 2035. They have a blueprint
which the plan lays out a three-step
program for returning Gaza to
self-governance and eventually
reintegrating Gaza into the regional
economy. And you could see how
futuristic the city actually looks. This
is going to be a template. Donald Trump
is going to use this to manipulate MAGA,
to manipulate conservatives on how we
could start building this out in
America. This is the prototype for what
will be a major smart city run of course
under smart city governance. For anyone
out there that doesn't know, we all have
talked about smart cities. Everybody
speaks of these smart cities, right?
People who are even semi-awake know that
the plan is smart cities. There's so
many articles out there about Elon Musk
and Bill Gates and all of these big tech
companies wanting smart cities, right?
But what people seem to forget is that
Donald Trump has openly been on board
with these smart cities. This isn't just
some democratic dystopian nightmare.
This is a new world order globalist
plan. And all it takes is for people
like Trump to say some things that make
sense like men are men and women are
women. and to rename something from a
smart city into a freedom city to trick
these people into thinking what he's
doing is for the betterment of mankind.
I could just see them sitting in a room
saying, "Hey, you know, we need to
remarket the smart city. Too many people
are on to it. Let's get a name. Freedom
City." Yeah, they'll fall for that. Oh,
and they have. That's like calling uh
after 911 they said the Patriot Act. Oh,
that sounds great. Yeah, we're going to
pat you down and run you through
scanners and everything when you go to
the airport. We're just every time they
take away a freedom, they just give it
some pleasant name.
Yeah. And it's interesting.
There's Yeah, this dude is is great. So,
this this article this article is from
2024, right? Uh and the the video
uh the video itself uh that came out uh
with Trump and Elon uh you know the the
the golden statue in in Gaza was just
recently, right? Yeah. So
it it's
I mean
what what else do you do you need to
know? Right. Trump Gaza, man. We fixing
to make it better.
this. Oh, this is interesting. Uh, so uh
uh this is also a video. You can you can
roll this video. Okay. Now, amidst a
looming threat of a potential takeover
by the United States of America,
President Donald Trump is again back to
making his comments. Greenland is
heading for parliamentary elections next
month. Now, the announcement comes as
Danish Prime Minister Met Meta
Frederickson met her British counterpart
Kier Star Tmer. Now, the island part of
the Danish territory will be holding
polls for the 31 seats on the 11th of
March. Following the announcement,
Greenland's parliament passed a law
blocking the political donations from
foreign nations, fearing external
interference. The incumbent prime
minister Mute Egi submitted his
re-election bid while adding that they
are in the midst of a very serious time.
Neri urged the citizens for cooperation
and has asked them to come together in
support of Greenland. The election comes
amidst Donald Trump's threat that the
United States wants to take complete
control of Greenland. In response, Prime
Minister has time and again reiterated
his stance that Greenland is not for
sale, but it is open to do business with
the American businesses.
This is a very important video about
Donald Trump acquiring Greenland, Donald
Trump acquiring Canada, the North
American Union, which you've heard me
talk about. But at the same exact time
as this talk about Green Greenland
holding a snap election, you also have
Donald Trump talking about leveling the
Gaza Strip and taking it over to rebuild
and stabilize the Middle East, which is
a part of the greater Israel plan. So,
while these two things are going on,
this is what the mainstream media is
pushing out there for conservatives.
Because conveniently, while Trump is
talking about expanding Israel, while
Trump is talking about acquiring
Greenland and making Canada the 51st
state, Trump's also signing an executive
order banning trans women from women's
sports. And this shows you just how low
and how far down critical thinking has
gone. Right? You throw a little caveat
at people out there, a little common
sense, right? Oh, men can't play women's
sports. Well, thank goodness, right?
They finally passed a bill. Everyone's
jumping for joy and celebrating. While
Donald Trump is literally bringing in
the new world order, he is bringing
about the North American Union. He is
helping expand Israel, the greater
Israel. This is all happening, by the
way, while he's calling this the golden
age for America. Just like in Rome, the
golden age of Rome, which was called Pax
Romana, which really consisted of a time
of peace and prosperity, but most
importantly an expansion, a territorial
expansion. And now we're seeing the new
world orders expansion occurring. This
is part of the new world orders map. And
this is another great way while they're
talking about these issues that
shouldn't be issues, they shouldn't be
discussed. We shouldn't be wasting our
time talking about things like men
playing women's sports. These should be
non-issues. But the majority of sheep,
this is an issue number one, just basic
common sanity, right? So distract them
with this nonsense. Make them celebrate
and cheer and look over and troll the
Democrats while all of this nonsense is
going on back and forth. Well, Trump is
bringing in exactly what the blueprint
for anybody out there who even has the
slightest knowledge of the new world
orders blueprints. He's bringing it in
right now. AI infrastructure. Yeah. The
blueprint for the Club of Rome, the
expansion of the North American Union.
Again, this isn't the first time that
Trump has talked about it. And really,
when you look at everything going on
now, this is just mind control and how
it works. They've been desensitizing
people to the North American Union
because Trump was talking about in 2019
the proposed United States acquisition
of Greenland. Trump was talking about
acquiring Canada. So, why do they keep
saying it without doing it? Well, the
most basic form of mind control is
repetition. again the 51st state with
Canada in the last 24 hours cuz they're
talking about these tariffs, these
tariffs which are going to be used to
acquire Canada. That's the whole purpose
that you're hearing about the tariffs
with Canada and Mexico. They throw China
into the mix for the stock market's sake
and to make it seem like they're not
deliberately trying to form a North
American Union. So throw China into the
mix with the tariffs. So it's just Trump
trying to go after people who aren't
fair to us. But it's really just about
building out the North American Union.
So here he is again talking about how it
would be in everybody's best interest to
bring in Canada as 51st state that he
could agree to to change your mind on
the terrorist. Well, we can always look
what I'd like to see Canada become our
51st state. We give them protection,
military protection. We we don't need
them to build our cars. I'd rather see
Detroit or South Carolina or any one of
our Tennessee, any one of our states
build the cars. They could do it very
easily. We don't need them for the cars.
We don't need them for lumber. We don't
need them for anything. We don't need
them for energy. We have more energy
than they do. We don't need them for
energy. Uh so I say, why are we doing
this? Why do we why are we willing to
lose between a hundred billion and $200
billion a year? We don't need them. As a
state, it's different. As a state, it's
much different. And there there are no
tariffs. So, I'd love to see that, but
uh some people say that would be a long
shot. Uh if people wanted to play the
game, right, it would be 100% certain
that they'd become a state, but a lot of
people don't like to play the game
because they don't have a threshold of
pain and there would be some pain. So
again, Trump is talking about buying
Greenland and Canada, suggesting Canada
merge with the United States become the
51st state. So what has happened in
Greenland? Well, you may have seen all
the stuff that occurred in Greenland
with Donald Trump's son, who recently
posted a picture of Donald Trump as the
baffiment in the mirror, right? Nothing
to see there, folks. Was just over there
with some of the alt-right media who are
just completely bought like Charlie
Kirk. But the reason people are drawn to
them is because they deliberately
strategically create all of this
nonsense about talking about men having
babies. Most easiest example to use with
the nonsense that we hear, right? He
says, "I think we're going to have it
and I think the people want to be with
us. Greenland contains critical natural
resources such as rare earth minerals
and uranium." Trump says US could
provide security to the island and
beyond. I don't know really what claim
Denmark has to it, but it would be a
very unfriendly act if they didn't allow
that to happen because it's for
protection of the free world. It's not
for us. It's for the free world. Right?
And then the sheepo hear that and they
hear about resources. The same thing
with Canada, right? Oh, the price of gas
might go down if we acquire if Canada
becomes first say oh the prices of goods
might oh okay right they don't care
about how this is the plan overall of
the globalists that they think that
they're actually against and they think
their hero Donald Trump is against right
all it takes is hey less taxes hey we're
going to investigate the IRS let's take
the whole government framework down so
we could put artificial intelligence in
place we could really trust that right
you know the same artificial
intelligence governance that the
globalists want and have been waiting
for you to accept and now they're
accepting
So, the other thing I want to talk about
with Greenland, for anybody else out
there who's paying attention to this, as
you know, Donald Trump is building out
the AI infrastructure in the United
States of America, which means they're
going to have these massive US data
centers. And of course, nobody realized
what the data inside of those data
centers are. It's you. It's everything
you've ever said on the internet. It's
your internet footprint. That means
every post you've ever made, every
upload you've ever done, everything is
inside of these data centers. and then
some of course to be able to monitor and
track you. So these data centers are
being put up with these quantum
computers and isn't it interesting to
note with Greenland a few coincidences
as to why also with the narratives out
there it's important for the US to have
Greenland on board. The average yearly
temperature in Greenland is about 0
degrees
-8° C. Okay, that's awfully cold, right?
It is all the way up there, right? And
did you know that quantum computers
cannot actually be outside, but they
need to be kept in very cold
temperatures? They need to be at
absolute zero. Well, being that the
yearly temperature in Greenland is
absolute zero, they probably have plans
to build at the northest point, I'm
sure, of Greenland to build data centers
maybe outdoors. I mean, I'm not saying
that they're going to just stick them
outside. they're not going to be
protected, but they're probably going to
be putting data putting these things out
there as well, which is part of why they
want to acquire Greenland. So, keep that
in mind with the data centers and the a
infrastructure. And
uh yeah, I didn't even think about that.
He had so many good points in there,
though. Like, I I love the the fact that
he's tracking like all he has to do is
say something normal like men are men
and women are women and everybody's
like, "Yeah." And then the agenda can
just unroll out. It's it's two steps
forward, one step back. I mean, if you
look here, what does that even mean? The
idiom two steps forward, one step back
describes a situation where progress is
made, but then setbacks occur causing a
temporary loss of ground though overall
there is still net achievement. So
advancement. So
basically the agenda is set. It has been
since, you know, Satan's been the god of
this world and the agenda is new world
order. That's what prophecy says. But
when when they start making certain laws
that take away certain freedoms or that
are just real tyrannical, the people get
unsettled and they want to uprise and
all that and they're like, "Okay, okay,
okay. Well, we'll we'll okay. Sorry
about that. We'll take away that little
thing." And then in the background,
they're putting two more steps in. you
know, it's like we'll take away one
thing, but we'll add two more. And then
when you guys finally let up, that law
will come back in. And so he's like,
they've created all this chaos, and
while he's saying, "Okay, we're getting
rid of all the woke stuff." Everybody's
like, "Yeah." And he's signing a
document. All right.
Uh and and oh, we're going to do this
and yay. And okay, AI governance and the
agenda is the same no matter who's who's
in office.
That's right. That's right. Well, and he
talked about the Club of Rome, right?
And the Club of Rome uh that was uh
1973 or 72 around that time. Uh there
was a book written uh by the by the club
of Rome or an article written by the
Club of Rome. Um and uh it's open, it's
public, it's uh it's in the archives. uh
and and they basically had created a map
and I think it's the next slide. If you
go to the next slide, let's see.
Oh yeah.
See, so this is uh the the
uh in 1973 the club of Rome published a
report titled the regionalized and
adaptive model of the global world
system which divided the world in 10
regions or kingdoms. And isn't it
interesting, we talked about it off the
show, yesterday after the show um about
the 10 kingdoms, right? Um and the 10
kingdoms uh those were the the 10
kingdoms um about those 10 regions,
right? With where the little horn came
out. Uh that's the papacy, right? That's
what what what we believe. But the
dispensationalists think it's the
future. Well, this is setting up the
whole thing for the future. 10 kingdoms,
they just play into the playbook of uh
Trump or whoever being the antichrist as
a person instead of the papal system
being the antichrist and uh forget that
the you know uh and mislead people and
and even to the point that uh people
think like hey
uh hello are you there? Oh no, did your
battery die or something? Uh Trumpist
are afraid and then that's what we
discussed yesterday. Uh that's where
this can lead to as well. And people
think like oh yeah but it's a dual uh a
dual uh fulfillment then like well it's
just misleading point here uh just to
put people on the on the wrong foot. But
it's also imperialism and easier to
control regions, right? when they have
10 regions to control instead of instead
of 200 something countries basically.
Wow, dude. Yeah, this is this is
prophetic. Wow, dude. Yeah, it's
Yeah, I mean the the more the more you
take over the Yeah. the the easier it is
to control because I mean America is
just going to become like this big
monopoly, I guess.
Yeah. And what did um Pax Romana mean?
Right. It's imperialism, right? It's
taking over. And what does Trump want to
do? Take over Canada, take over
Greenland.
And uh you see Russia having uh also
those older states back, right? Yeah.
See that? Even more than that. So what
my my colleague is going through uh my
my friend in Slovakia is saying that uh
that uh his uh president is kind of like
uh he wants he want he's kind of pro
Putin it's not a coincidence and you see
I think uh is it um let's see there a
little part of Finland or so is taken
back over and other parts I mean I don't
know if war is coming I'm not predicting
anything. I'm not saying anything that's
going to happen, but if this map, if
this map is is drawn by the elites,
there must be something, you know, going
to happen at some point. Well, what a
perfect way to bring about new world
order is order out of chaos. So, what's
what's the most chaos you can have is
war.
And when people want peace, when they
say peace and safety, sudden destruction
will come upon them. That destruction is
the return of Christ. So, I believe
yeah, there is going to be a war
coming and it might be stopped by quote
unquote aliens that are coming to save
the day.
And who knows, man.
There's some great comments going on in
the in the comment section there.
Um, is there another slide?
I think this is it, but I'm not sure.
You can try. That's it. Wow, dude. This
is just this is just getting more all
the evidence is just building up to
where you cannot deny this. I mean,
recap what what uh if you had to run
through all the slides, recap what all
we saw. We saw
um the hidden hand from all the leaders
all over the world, Freemasonry. We
saw the the connection with not just
Hollywood but
also the the
um political leaders hooking up with
that Abria what's her name Molina
Abramovic the
Satanist and they're all involved Marina
Marina Marina Abramovich and they're all
connected to these uh soul cooking
spirit cooking parties
and her saying that she met a shaman in
Rome, saying that Trump was the greatest
magician and he's got a slogan called
Maga, which means magician or if that
doesn't sound, you know, people hear
magician, they don't think it doesn't
have a powerful enough term, but it
means witch. Um, yeah, then Clinton
saying that his wife communicates with
the dead. Somebody in the chat said they
saw that Abraham Lincoln's wife
communicated with the dead. And it's
it's pretty common. It seems like these
president's wife surprised me. Yeah.
Yeah. It doesn't surprise me at all.
And Yeah. And and if you watched the
last show, you showed all the people
that are connected with Trump and how
they all have the same agenda, pushing
AI, pushing Catholicism, pushing
um space, you know, exploration and all
this stuff. I don't know. I don't even
know where you stand on this, but I
don't I think exploring space is a big
fraud, a big waste of money. It's It's
not doing anything. I agree because I
don't believe that anyone's even
traveling space. I don't believe that
according to the Bible. Nobody Nobody
went to the moon. Nobody went to the
moon. Nobody went to the moon. And uh
the the Bible says that there's a guy
himself said it. Yeah, they do. They
they admit it. Yeah. Yeah. He he she he
said it's us flat out like uh No, we
didn't. Yeah, I like that terminology
used flat out. But they they the Bible
says that there's a firmament and Oh,
sorry. That separates waters above from
the waters below. There's nothing up
there but water. It's it's above a glass
dome firmament and the the sun, moon,
and stars are in that firmament. There's
people that say um that the firmament
means the means the water the waters
above are clouds or the ozone layer or
something like that. Well, then you got
a big problem when Genesis says that the
sun, moon, and stars are in the clouds
or in our atmosphere, you know?
So, look into the topic. Like don't
don't just turn a blind eye and think
that we couldn't have been lied about
where we live or I mean the the
textbooks say that we crawled out of a
primordial soup and this all this
happened with a big bang of nothingness
and and we evolved like that's in the
scientific textbooks. So if they can lie
about that then they can also lie about
where we live. And there there is a
reason everybody says what's the reason?
The reason is
because the ultimate deception is this
alien deception. And without lying about
where we live, you could never believe
in big bang. You could never believe in
evolution. And ultimately never believe
in an alien deception because there are
no aliens coming through a firmament
that with water above. So
correct. Correct. Yeah. Where'd that
even come from? Well, we got on a rant
there. Yeah. Well, um I don't know.
That's that's a Oh, yeah. Yeah. Yeah.
Because because he's also like um so we
we didn't go to the moon. Uh but the
thing is it's like he's all these guys
who went to the moon were Freemasons as
well, right? So Oh, yeah. Freemasons.
Never trust a Freemason. He he he he
makes he makes a a pact or a promise or
or a leg how do you say it? Like uh he
swears basically lie that he even to his
wife to everyone. So if uh if a person
is a Freemason, don't trust the word cuz
they're they're allowed to lie. I just I
just want to flat smack right here. I
just want to um while people are here,
just just search the term Hebrew earth.
I'm not saying anything about the shape
or anything. Just Hebrew earth. Now
check it out. Every image is going to be
the same. All I say was Hebrew earth. I
mean, this should tell you something
that there's something worth looking
into that this is what the Hebrews
believed. I mean, so if they were the
ones that wrote the Bible, were in touch
with God, hearing from God, and that's
that's what they believed, then don't
just think these people were ignorant
imbeciles, you know, they they knew
better than we know. Yeah. Well, and I
think uh Josh meant me me me me me me me
me me me me me me me me me me me me me
me me me me me me me mentioned that in
one of your shows or you on his shows,
but he said like u the idea that that
struck me like the idea uh then how
close God actually is because if if you
if you think that the the the the
universe is expanding all the time,
right? It's expanding expanding, then
where where is God? He's he's outside
outside the creation, right? So if
that's the case
uh like how do how do I explain that
like
uh where does he reside then right you
you know what I mean right yeah and it's
which way's up expanding then then how
far is God then well God doesn't doesn't
it doesn't mind his business what we're
doing here right right but in that
system like how close is God then right
God is pretty close closer than we
Yep. We know that that struck me. That
was like, wow, that is there's there's
no up in the in the idea that we've been
taught that we're this ball flying
around and ever expanding vacuum like
which way's up? I mean, which way is
Jesus coming from? Which way's heaven?
Well, yeah. Well, funny uh that you say
that like, okay, every eye will see him,
right? How is that possible if if if one
half have the world is dark and there's
nothing nothing there. Secondly, uh what
is interesting uh there was another
thing that I wanted to say
um but I forgot. Yeah, there I mean
there there are so many things that uh
uh that just don't add up. Oh yeah,
there was one thing in the Bible that
says that the sun stood still. Yes.
which is the Bible doesn't say like the
earth sits still. No, the sun sits
still, right? Yep. Huge
one. Yeah, man. This this is why I
cannot wait to get this presentation
done
because I don't know. I just know the
things that convinced me and I can't
wait to like put those all together
because I'll show scripture and then
science that proves it. You look at
stars with a telescope, they look like
light bulb. They look like a LED light
underwater. That's exactly what the
Bible says they are. That everything up
there is lights in the firmament, the
the waters above. And uh you look at an
eclipse, they it looks like the sun and
moon are relatively the same size
eclipsing each other. Now, you could
believe the model that the sun is a
million times bigger than Earth and it's
93 million miles away and and the moon
is really close and they just happen to
be the same distance to do that. But
that doesn't that doesn't make sense
when you actually look at um sun rays.
There's Yeah, there's another thing that
that that that that's very interesting
to me. What I watched a few times I you
see the sun up there and then over there
you see still the moon like h like half
or even like a little little piece of
it. I'm like so there's the moon,
there's the sun. So where's Earth in
between? If the earth is is in between,
right? It's that's the shadow, right?
That's what they what they tell you.
Like, so what is in between then?
Good question. Yeah. I mean, this is
what is the shadow then, right? This is
what we observe with our eyes. And if
you follow the trace of light, there's
some back here, some in the foreground,
some this these rays are spled out and
they are pointing you to the source of
light. That's not 93 million miles away.
These lines would be parallel straight
down if that were the case. Another
thing, um, orbit of Earth around Sun.
This is, this was like really eye
opening to me when I just looked at
this.
So, let's see. Let's open this
up. Man, some people are just in for a
surprise with this now. They came for
the Trump stuff and but bonus bonus
bonus. Yeah. So right here I think this
is like June. This is January. This is
July I think. So at this time of the
year the stars are this way, right?
Because they're opposite side of the
sun. So all this these months you're
looking at the stars this way.
What about when you're over here and the
these months and you're looking at the
stars this way? Opposite side of the
sun. I mean, this is 93 million miles
here, then the the the circumference or
whatever the width of the sun, then 93
million miles more, and now you're
looking at stars this direction, and yet
the northern star never moves. The
northern star never you're looking at
stars on the left, stars on the right.
The southern the the northern star never
moves. I mean, you can't have that. You
can't be on an axis corkcrewing through
outer space, ever expanding universe.
Everything is expanding and moving. And
for thousands of years, constellations
have never changed. That's how they use
the astrolab that it still works today.
You can still predict where the stars
are and all that
stuff. But yeah, so much contradiction
there. Yeah, man.
We'll do that.
I love like these conversations, man. I
I love like the stuff you've been
showing has been so eye opening. And if
if anybody thought that Trump was going
to save the day, that he's a Christian,
that
he's, you know, for us, I mean, this
should just show that he's he's part of
the club. The agenda is the same no
matter right or left. Both wings of the
same bird.
And that's what the Bible says that
Satan is the god of this world. And we
know that
ultimate agenda is one world order, one
world government, one world religion.
And everything is coming, everything's
coming into place. Trump is the one
saying, "Yep, Stargate." I mean, it was
like his first month as a president
unrolling out Stargate. What is
Stargate? It's total AI governance.
Every surveillance camera, everything's
going to be analyzed by AI tracking.
They don't have to hire a security guard
anymore to watch a bunch of monitors.
It's computers that never sleep. But
even think about this. Think about this.
Uh your your smart home, everything will
be controlled. Oh, you're using too much
uh too much energy. It will shut you
shut you off. You eat too much food. We
lock your fridge up. Right. So, it's
like they control everything. Or you've
been a naughty boy at some point, right?
Yeah. You you've been naughty. You don't
get your social score went down and you
can't even eat this week, man. Turn the
light off.
Yeah. So So where's where's the hope?
What do we do? You know, get close to
God. We know detriment is coming. The
only answer is Jesus. The only answer is
God's word. The only answer is Bible
prophecy. If you don't know Christ, if
you don't believe the Bible, if you
don't believe God, it's time to open it
up. It's time to start seeking. It's
time to start asking God, "If you're
real, reveal yourself to me in this word
because the things I'm
seeing are are fearful, scary, and it
lines up with what people like what
these Bible believers believe. So, who
are you, God? Reveal yourself to me. I
want a relationship with you. How do I
have that?" And just seek relationship
with Christ. Get in his word. Pray
because one day Christ is coming soon
and the line's drawn in the sand. You
know, choose ye this day whom you will
serve. I don't even want to be around
for what's coming. I don't I don't care
if I'm offered the whole world. What
profits a man gains? The whole world
lose his own soul. We're all going to
pass. We're not guaranteed
tomorrow. And you have to think about
that, you know. And so I just hope that
if anybody's watching this, this has
been eye opening in a way that made them
want to really study out prophecy and
choose to have a relationship with
Christ.
Amen, man. Thank you so much for all
your research. Do you got more for us
later? You got some more stuff lined up?
Oh. Oh, man. We got lots of episodes,
man. We can
do year round. Awesome. Okay. Things are
things are moving forward the whole
time, right? So, there's always
something to talk about. But I I do have
a lot prepared, right? I I I think it it
was hilarious the first time that I that
I came over, right? Um it was too funny
because I I had so much information and
then after that I came back home after
the two episodes that we did, I broke
everything down uh into 16 episodes or
whatever. And even that is crazy because
now we did two episodes out of the third
episode.
Oh, that's crazy.
So, yeah, we've got a lot. So, if you
wouldn't have broke it down, it'd be
like a 24-hour live stream
probably or more.
We've got so much so much to cover, so
much things going on and so much things
connected and everything connected to
Rome and it's it's insane. It's and it's
just the tip of the iceberg really what
we're showing. Dude, there's still stuff
that we have no clue, man. And we'll
never know. Yeah. Wow, man. Well, thank
you so much for coming on, dude. Always
a pleasure. If you guys uh want to check
I wish I could tell them to go to your
channel or something, but Minnow is
exclusively here on Candid Truth. Uh
third third member, third host of Candid
Truth. So, check out some other videos,
man. We'll put some links in in the
description of other videos that Minnow
has done and you guys will see. Man, the
evidence only points to one thing that
all roads lead to Rome. Well, thanks,
man. You have a good night out there in
Vegas and get some good sleep and
and uh awesome, man. First some dinner.
Some dinner. Yeah. Awesome. First
dinner, then sleep. That's right.
Thanks, man. Thanks, man.
Thank you guys for joining us at Candid
Truth. If you were blessed by this, if
it was eye opening, please give it a
thumbs up. It's a free and simple way to
support this ministry. It really does
help. Helps the video get into the
algorithm so more people can see it. If
you want to give to this ministry so
that we can continue to do this, we we
rely on your support. So, there's many
ways to do that. Go to cantruth.org. We
got all the different digital options
you can go there. We also have
merchandise. If you like t-shirts, we
got t-shirts with scripture on it. Some
that say be cool, use your brain, and uh
one of the shirts I'm wearing right
now, the Candid Truth Brain logo. We got
all these shirts on there, and we get
about $5 per shirt. So, we really
appreciate if you guys buy that merch
from us. It really helps. And we love
you guys. We can't do this without you.
And we will see you next time